alors qu'elle venait de suspendre une
nouvelle fois son compte Instagram les
fans de Britney Spears se sont inquiétés
ont pris une initiative plutôt
surprenante
[Musique]
vidéo postées par la chanteuse sur ses
réseaux sociaux préoccupe de
non alors les autorités sont-elles
vraiment allé chez Britney content elle
constaté si peu d'infos ont futé après
l'appel des fans la police a tout de
même souhaité leur livrer des nouvelles
rassurantes je peux confirmer que nous
ne pensons pas que Britney Spears soit
en danger ni qu'elle soit blessée
une prise d'initiative qui n'en tout cas
pas du tout fait plaisir à la star
internationale j'adore mes fans mais
cette fois ça va trop loin ma vie privée
a été atteinte
[Musique]
alors quand je vous dis qu'elle s'est
retirée elle-même suspendue son compte
mais c'est vrai qu'elle avait voilà la
poster des choses moi ça me fait pas
mais voilà mettez des petites étoiles où
il fallait tout ça je sais pas
c'est une jeune fille à la dérive c'est
terrible
attention
l'initiative des fans remarquable parce
que quelques jours avant au restaurant
il y avait un gros problème et son mari
avait dû prendre la parole parce que
elle était filmée par des clients et il
y avait une altercation un problème donc
l'inquiétude des fans est monté quant à
la désactiver le compte ce qui est
inhabituel pour elle les fans se sont
inquiétées moi je trouve extraordinaire
qu'ils aient appelé la police parce
qu'elle aurait pu être en danger alors
après elle dit ma vie privée a été
altérée etc mais pas du tout c'est la
préoccupation vous faites une action
volontaire sur les réseaux et que et que
les gens au bout la police et moi
j'étais inquiet pour donc je trouve que
ce qu'on fait
pour tous
bravo les fans par exemple
sur Instagram
et au moins voilà
ils disent voilà je me retire pour telle
raison alors que il y a un complot
Britney Spears en fait en ce moment
c'est depuis quelques temps les fans
pensent qu'elle est sous l'emprise de
son mari et qu'en fait c'est pas elle
qui poste c'est lui qui la filme et
c'est lui qui poste les trucs et c'est
lui qui répond etc et qui met les ce
qu'on appelle les captions là les
légendes en fait voilà donc elle serait
sous emprise de du mari et il y a
beaucoup quand vous lisez les
commentaires sur son Instagram moi
j'adore ça même
[Applaudissements]
mais mais voilà on prétend que il la
drogerait que il suffirait des
médicaments que ils ne soignerait pas sa
bipolarité et qu'elle serait dans cet
état là et qu'à chaque fois qu'elle est
dans un état ce qu'on appelle les états
maniaques
j'aime bien moi je trouve que j'ai
retourné au mauvais moment en plus
c'est joli hein
c'est sympathique hein
franchement là il fallait pas mettre un
diamant là ça sert à rien
j'espère qu'elle va revenir sur scène
elle avait un contrat incroyable à Las
Vegas qu'elle a perdu c'est une grande
artiste et on lui souhaite beaucoup de
courage